thank you all for meeting on such short
notice yes yes Michael Scott Dunder
Mifflin what is the purpose of this
meeting seeing as it's Valentine's Day I
felt it would be apropos to have a
little refresher course on romance in
the workplace perfect yes it is quite
apropriate Carry On First Things First
an office romance is permissible not
something you'd expect to hear from
corporate well guess what saber is 100
tolerant of office romances speaking of
Gabe I don't see Aaron at this meeting
uh I also don't see Andy oh
boom face I get it Andy's slamming my
girlfriend very funny what I do not
approve of however is public displays of
affection or pdas pdas are totally
Superfluous to a happy healthy office
Romance
a perfect example look at Jim and Pam
yeah
yeah what us they don't touch they don't
kiss you would hardly even know that
they were husband and wife did it yeah
love it keep it going okay so pdas
that's going to include behaviors such
as hugging kissing uh booby honking yeah
booby hunking sure but honking butt
honking yep all the hunkings the woman
you start in a Crouch position and you
lose sure basically there's no precise
definition but you know it when you see
it
Chicago
are you guys listening to this
what are you talking about me and Holly
yeah
maybe you find your own chair
so we kiss occasionally not occasionally
all the time yeah and it's not just the
kissing it's the flirtatious Whispering
the flirtation's tickling whispering and
tickling have their place in business
that thing where you softly exhale on
her neck I
okay yeah that's pretty hot I will give
you that look you are all Hypocrites you
all do it Michael
confession I have done PDA in the office
thank you I have that intercourse in the
office all right as has Angela Dwight as
has Ryan as as Kelly as has Meredith as
has Phyllis as has Daryl as has Creed as
has Michael and as has Holly as has
Kevin with who she goes to another
school okay fine no more PDA good okay
you win but here's what we are gonna do
we are going to designate one of our
closets as a hookup Zone Anything Goes
what if two couples want to go at the
same time we have two classes no no
we're gonna have three closets one for
each base no homers yes and what is the
hookup Zone policy on masturbation
Pro yes what no no it's great I love
working at Dunder Mifflin a division of
Taliban Enterprises
I hate those shoes oh
are we starting please all right let's
start with celery
what are you doing oh I'm sorry are you
in some subconscious level seeing this
as me toying with your manhood of course
I am I invented that Boca 2002 you've
seen the tapes what no I I just you are
being coached by me I'm sorry Jack I
have to take this yes may I please speak
to Pizza the fake phone call to buy time
in an emergency classic Donaghey okay
fine you got me game over no no this
just levels the playing field going mono
Amano against a real adversary me
the ultimate game Jack Donaghey playing
with himself
it's a jack-off so your department
Banned Me from attending games just
because I yell you suck at the Players
according to the complaint you yelled at
five-year-old girls Jose
I thought I was having this meeting with
Ron Swanson I'm afraid that Ron
Swanson's currently dead oh I'm his
daughter April Swanson
and it's his last wish that I have this
meeting with you
I represent the ultimate frisbee league
and money has an ultimate league yes and
we keep running into conflict
I will join your team um I'm sorry
um what we need when does practice start
and do you provide the jerseys what
color are the jerseys by the way what's
our team name are we the lightning
now I have to tell you I don't actually
work in the parks department I'm a nurse
seriously
that's great news I have the weirdest
thing on my arm
can you see this
every time
attention Squad everyone gather round
I've been researching ways to raise
morale and I found an interesting
article in a scientific journal oh was
it from the American Journal of no one
cares
according to a recent study the physical
act of smiling can improve your mood I
suggest we give it a shot
um
now you're a try
big smiles bigger bigger great now we
just have to stay like this for the next
two hours can you feel it working I
don't have any enamel on my teeth so the
cold air is excruciating maybe you
brushed your teeth once in a while this
wouldn't be a problem I do brush my
teeth they're decaying from acid reflux
you're birthing yourself foreign
girl guys seriously Too much exposure to
Air and they will turn to dust this
isn't working out as well as I'd hoped
time for the next level forced laughing
foreign
I know your shift is over and you've had
a challenging night but I think I found
a new way to raise morale follow me
to the briefing room
[Music]
what's all this it's an after work hang
just trying to turn up as it were we got
uh snacks games decorations chairs yes
chairs cool maybe we can Mill around and
small talk about how some of us are big
lying Liars who lie all the time like a
bunch of liars Rosa I don't think that's
good party combo uh maybe we should just
name our favorite sailing knot I'll
start
the bowline
how about some tunes
cool Merry-Go-Round music yeah John
Phillips Sousa the Skrillex of his day
come on people hit the Dance Floor have
a good time why is no one having a good
time I specifically requested it Gina
why aren't you dancing I can't I'm in
the middle of a feud with a that's not a
knife guy from Crocodile Dundee
he's being a real [ __ ] fine I guess
I'll just stop the party I didn't
realize it ever started enough
listen
I don't need an atta boy just for doing
my job okay but I do think it's positive
that this can open a conversation about
self-defense and how each of us need to
take action what I'm saying is don't do
what Dina did
I'm sorry what he said don't be like you
Dina took upon herself to physically
confront the thief and while it worked
out okay this time it could have turned
into Serious injury or death or God
forbid a lawsuit
I'm obviously joking a lawsuit would not
be as bad as death the point is we have
a policy for this so if you see
something suspicious report it don't try
to handle it yourself yeah we all know
what the policy is but what was I
supposed to do just stand there and make
brown like Jonah what did Jonah do well
I I didn't actually do anything exactly
he just sat there and watched a guy Rob
the store thank you that is what you
should all do in the future thank you
Jonah for actually following protocol oh
well
yeah I mean you know you guys came up
with the policy I just knew it and
followed it it's appreciated oh my God
just sleep with him already
okay what if someone steals a baby what
then do
you
there
and wearing a bomb then wouldn't you
want him to steal it I'm trying to
picture a scenario in which somebody
plans what if it's Baby Hitler
a very good question is it I think you
gotta kill that baby Hitler yeah how
would you know that that baby was going
to grow up to be Hitler what if that
baby was going to grow up to be the
exact opposite of Hitler Churchill no
Lance Bass interesting Oprah yeah Oprah
Oprah you gotta save that baby gotta
save it I'm more of an Ellen person
oh it's fun when she dances anyway what
I'm saying is don't be Edina be a Jonah
wait you guys what if it's baby Oprah
but the person's stealing it is Beyonce